hola a todos en el último vídeo
estábamos viendo campos vectoriales
cuyas componentes verticales fueran cero
verdad y teniendo así vectores que solo
apuntan en la dirección digamos
horizontal es decir en el sentido a la
derecha por ejemplo oa la izquierda
verdad entonces más o menos así se
visualizan este tipo de campos
vectoriales es decir no tienen nada de
componente en la dirección vertical ni
hacia arriba ni hacia abajo y luego
aterrizamos la idea de que la
divergencia de nuestro campo vectorial
paradas la divergencia del campo
vectorial b tiene que ver justamente con
la derivada parcial de la primera
componente con respecto a x verdad pero
en este vídeo quiero hacer justamente lo
contrario quiero justamente que la
componente horizontal sea 0 y la
componente vertical si puede ser
cualquier otra cosa verdad entonces la
componente horizontal tiene que ser 0
pero la componente vertical puede ser
nuestra función q
x de verdad entonces si nosotros tenemos
este tipo de campos vectoriales la forma
en la que visualizamos esto es similar
al caso anterior solo que sólo vamos a
tener flechas apuntando hacia arriba o
hacia abajo verdad entonces nuestra
divergencia del campo vectorial ve la
divergencia del campo vectorial b y por
supuesto esto siempre tiene que ser en
algún punto x que digamos si suponemos
que es positiva pues pensemos de qué
forma se puede visualizar esto por
ejemplo podríamos pensar en un punto en
donde no está ocurriendo nada es decir q
vale 0 verdad y entonces para qué las
partículas estén alejando por arriba
tiene que apuntar justamente hacia
arriba verdad estaríamos pensando que q
tiene que ser positivo y por abajo tiene
que apuntar hacia abajo entonces
estaríamos pensando que q tiene que ser
negativo en este caso fíjense que
estamos viendo que al movernos en la
dirección vertical es decir en la
dirección d
si vamos de abajo hacia arriba entonces
vamos de negativo a 0 y positivo es
decir la función que está creciendo
quiere decir que nuestra derivada
parcial de q con respecto de la variable
y tiene que ser positiva verdad así que
parece que esto corresponde a que la
divergencia tiene que ser positiva
también verdad entonces podríamos
también formular otra situación en donde
a lo mejor en este punto apunta también
hacia arriba verdad aquí tendríamos que
q es positivo entonces para que la
divergencia sea positiva la tasa de
entrada verdad tiene que ser digamos muy
pequeña es digamos podremos pensar que
es casi casi cero comparada con la tasa
de salida verdad entonces digamos aquí
estoy mezclando notación pero podríamos
pensar que es muy muy muy grande verdad
y otra vez al movernos de abajo hacia
arriba en la dirección vertical verdad
tendremos que q aumenta
la variable ye lo cual refuerza esta
idea de que la derivada parcial de q con
respecto de y tiene que estar
relacionada con la deriva con la
divergencia verdad y podrías esbozar más
circunstancias verdad que pasaría por
ejemplo si en lugar de que aquí
inicialmente apunte hacia arriba apunta
hacia abajo verdad o podrías esbozar
casos para entender cuando la
divergencia es igual a cero pero quería
que viéramos digamos que esta derivada
parcial también está relacionada con la
divergencia y cuando lo combinamos con
lo que teníamos anteriormente
técnicamente es lo único que necesitamos
para calcular la divergencia entonces si
nos hacemos espacio verdad y aquí
ponemos nuevamente digamos bien nuestro
campo vectorial ve que depende de
nuestras variables xy de verdad y en
general puede tener dos entradas la
entrada x
perdón de entrada px de entrada q de x
de verdad entonces la forma en la que
calculamos la divergencia de nuestro
campo vectorial b y por supuesto como
siempre estaremos hablando en un punto
particular x
pues se calcula como la suma de las dos
derivadas parciales que encontramos la
derivada parcial de p con respecto de x
más la derivada parcial de q con
respecto de g
y esta esta es la fórmula para la
divergencia de un campo vectorial y
espero que en realidad esto ya no sea
sólo una fórmula más sino que realmente
comprendas de dónde salió
cuál es la intuición detrás de esta
fórmula verdad que cuando veas estas
derivadas parciales por ejemplo la
derivada parcial de p con respecto de x
estés pensando justamente en la
dirección horizontal de nuestro campo
vectorial y en este punto pensemos que
hay una una mayor salida de partículas
de agua
fluido del que estemos hablando verdad y
que cuando veas la derivada parcial de q
con respecto de y entonces pienses
justamente en lo mismo pero para la
componente vertical y lo sorprendente de
aquí es que como deducimos todo esto fue
simplemente con casos particulares y muy
simples verdad pero nosotros sabemos que
por ejemplo déjenme borrar estas flechas
en realidad los casos más generales no
son siempre horizontales o verticales
verdad sino que pueden ser así y así y
podemos tener muchas combinaciones de
flechas por acá verdad podríamos tener
todo esto y en realidad este caso lo
podemos entender muy bien ahora con esta
fórmula esencialmente porque todos estos
vectores los podemos descomponer verdad
podemos descomponer los vectores en su
componente horizontal y en su componente
vertical verdad y por eso es que
tendremos esta suma de estas derivadas
verdad ahora bien si quieres pensarlo en
términos del fluido verdad pensemos
en este punto por ejemplo de aquí y
ahora dibujamos una pequeña caja
alrededor de este punto y entonces nos
fijamos justamente en la cantidad de
fluido que entra por estos lados pero
estos lados son digamos corresponden a
la parte vertical y estos corresponden a
la parte horizontal verdad y si
tuviéramos un vector digamos que entra
en diagonal pues simplemente vemos como
contribuye cada una de las componentes
de este vector para entrar en esta
cajita por los lados correspondientes
verdad entonces esta es la razón por la
que sólo pensamos en estos dos términos
para la divergencia así pensamos como
contribuye cada cada componente digamos
en cada lado de este de esta cajita
verdad pero bueno de todas formas lo
importante de la divergencia es que solo
involucra y estos dos términos estas
derivadas parciales